et le sport c'est avec Anthony rche oui
on va commencer par quelques petits
résultats en basket étoile des cheminaux
de trappe s'est incliné ce weekend sur
le parquet de vanenve 89 à 68 la saison
ne décolle pas vraiment pour le CT
englué dans le dans le bas de tableau de
de National 2 on reste à trappe mais
cette fois-ci c'est du football les
Trappistes se sont imposés sur la
pelouse de herbly sur le score de de
buts à Z0 et sont désormais 8e de la
poule B de Promotion d'Honneur et on
continue avec du football premier sujet
de cette page au sport oui j- 6 Wilfried
j- 6 avant le premier choc vraiment
important du Football Club de Versailles
il s'agit de Coupe de France ils jouent
leur 6e tour déjà un beau parcours ils
vont jouer sainttoin
leomô ce weekend nous avons suivi leur
match de championnat juste avant parce
qu'il fallait bien se préparer c'est une
répétition avant l'entrée voilà
répétition avant avant avant le
spectacle imag d'éodim
moine un coup du chapeau de Grégory
Lefort capitaine du FC Versailles
hauteur notamment de cette tête des
croisé une victoire nette 3 buts à un
face à saint-toin lomô une troème place
consolidée en Division d'Honneur et le
dossier championnat est rangé au placard
pour une semaine au menu de dimanche
prochain la prestigieuse Coupe de France
et un 6e tour face au lilas avec tous
ces ingrédients Versailles se prépare au
mieux pour ce choc on a un peu mieux
géré la deuxième période mais cétait
important de gagner on a les quat points
donc maintenant la place à ce fux match
de Coupe de France sans se mettre trop
de pression mais c'est vrai que c'est un
un objectif le club a pris a pris goût
ces dernières
saisons à vivre des des belles émotions
et on souhaite pouvoir aller le plus
loin possible les Bleus sont les
derniers escapés du département dans
cette édition 2013 et Franck Bentolila
mesure bien l'attente autour de ce match
ces rencontres de Coupe toujours à part
qu'il faut gérer dès le début de la
semaine dans la préparation et la
gestion de la pression je sens bien le
un petit peu le non pas la pression mais
ce que ce que ça suscite au sein du club
aussi bien de la part dirigeants des
enfants bon la municipalité c'est vrai
que c'est un certain engouement ça
montera forcément au f au fil des jours
mais on va rester dans notre notre
philosophie de travail et puis peutre
qu'on aborder un pe peu tirs au but
vendredi sur la dernière séance mais
c'est essentiellement l'état d'esprit ce
qu'on va y mettre pour pour remporter ce
match coup PRS puisque il y a pas de PO
il a juste un vainqueur et et un éliminé
dimanche
prochain
que Versailles fera tout pour
éviter petite correction Versailles joue
les lilas ce weekend en Coupe de France
et ils ont joué saint-toin l en
championnat ce weekend dernier voilà
pour cette ce petit rectificatif on
poursuit cette séquence ce sport avec
trois invités qui nous ont rejoint en
plate on va parler de roller Hock avec
les chocks d'éancour qui marqu un coup
d'arrêt dans leur saison avec une
première défaite et puis on va parler
pour l'instant du tawendo oui de tawendo
il y avait les les championnats
départementaux ce weekend à Andry où le
TKD 78 était présent pour en parler avec
nous sur ce plateau ce soir Éric Nodin
président du TKD bonsoir bonsoir et et
Canel maerois comattente à l'origine
mais coach pour les les championnats
départementaux c'est ça bonsoir bonsoir
à vous euh j'ai envie de dire que sur
ces championnats départementaux c'est un
peu la rasia vous aviez 10 athlètes qui
postulaient au au aux médailles et
résultat 100 % de podium
exactement je vais laisser ça pas l'air
de vous surprendre très calmement
effectivement nous avons 100 % de
résultat et alors
on est habitué effectivement à des à des
bons résultats bon faire 100 % c'est
vrai que c'est quand même pas tous les
jours c'est quelque chose de de notable
on était assez heureux euh maintenant on
fait régulièrement pas mal de podiums
sentraîne pour ça on s'entraîne aussi
pour ça quand même on a entraînement
compétiteur deux deux à trois fois dans
la semaine sinon on a encore
entraînement technique parce queil faut
quand même avoir de la technique pour
être bon en combat et là donc on a eu
SEP médailles d'or deux médailles
d'argent et une médaille de bronze c'est
c'est c'est c'est satisfaisant quand
même enfin ou c'est plus une épreuve de
rodage c'est c'estes championnats
départementaux déjà c'était assez tôt
dans l'année dans dans l'année parce que
on va avoir les îles de France qui vont
avoir lieu le
8 9 décembre à Paris dans le 14e
arrondissement donc là on est tous
qualifiés pour aller aux îles de France
et les six premiers seront qualifiés
pour aller au championnat de France donc
on voit les photos des des combats prouè
ce weekend
justement donc champion des
déportementaux obj at quels sont les
objectifs pour les régionaux les
championnats de France je crois que vous
vous êtes déjà qualifié pour les les
championnats de France c'est ça je suis
qualifié pour aller au championnat de
France parce que j'ai fait un podium
l'an dernier encore 3e j'ai perdu contre
Anne Caroline graff qui a fait cette
année un podium au
j d'arent médaille d'argent ça en PO
lourd donc votre objectif reste quand
même le titre cette année personnel
voilà un titre au moins c'est la
retrouver et la battre ou sans quoi
toujours là montrer que je suis je suis
présente le je me tourne vers le
président quand même heureux et et
satisfait de ce weekend pleinement
satisfait c'est c'est clair que des
choses comme ça c'est c'est des choses
qu'on aimerait voir tout le temps
voilà pas laisser de place aux autres
c'est clair que c'est c'est de temps en
temps agréable dans le monde du sport on
n'est pas juste là pour participer on
est aussi là pour gagner donc donc on
est tous très très heureux de ça et
c'est clair qu'on on donne rendez-vous à
tout le monde les 89 décembbres pour les
IDF et j'ai bon espoir que plusieurs de
nos athlètes aux IDF se se qualifient
pour les championnats de France les IDF
championnats régionaux oui tout à fait î
de France de France exactement et est-ce
que vous souffrez un petit peu des
quotas qu'on connaît sur les
compétitions internationales pour bah on
sait que un seul athlète français
notamment pour la France peut participer
au quota sachant qu'il y a des très bons
athlètes bah comme Canel comme votre
frère qui sont régulièrement sur les
podiums nationaux il y a effectivement
une souffrance par rapport au cô que ce
soit bon les Jos c'est le l'équipe de
France et c'est la fédération qui
choisit qui y envoie mais même sur
certaines compétitions international nos
athlètes n'ont parfois pas le droit de
se présenter si l'équipe de France se
présente ça c'est dommage parce que
c'est encore une histoire de cota ou
c'est une histoire de règles et on a
certains nos combattants qui pourraient
faire des de très très belles choses sur
des compétitions internationales sur des
Open
par exemple en Allemagne en Belgique en
Italie enfin on a quelques-uns qui qui
les font et et c'est vrai qu'on regrette
de de pas forcément pouvoir aller sur
certaines compétitions où je suis
certain que certains des nôres feraient
de beaux résultat donc prochain objectif
Canel les régionaux début décembre déjà
oui là je serai coach encore parce que
comme je suis qualifié là pour moi le
prochain objectif c'est le 1er 2
décembre le tournoi international de
Paris qui a lieu à Coubertin et là c'est
du très haut niveau c'est les personnes
qu'on a vu au Gio qui vont revenir à
Paris pour combattre et se retrouver
l'actualité c'était les championnats
département mentau mais au TKD 78 il y a
aussi une autre actualité qui est en
train un petit peu de de se construire
c'est la nouvelle section sel défense le
sel défense coréen exactement donc le
auchinsou je pas auchinsou vous avez
bien entendu leinétais pas sûr d'avir
bien entendu la auchinsou qui est donc
vraiment un art martial une branche du
tawendo qui est vraiment orienté
exclusivement cel
défense pour cette section qu'on voulait
ouvrir depuis des années la mairie de
montinu nous a trouvé une salle courant
décembre donc c'est qu'on ouvre en cours
d'année c'est un petit peu ça s'est fait
un peu un bruit pour point mais on va
démarrer dans cette section avec un
voire deux enseignants diplômés pour
donner le cours mais alors qu'est-ce que
c'est le chinsul parce que pour qu'on
comprenne un peu ça ça se rapproche du
crave Maga un petit peu c'est ça c'est
c'est vraiment de de la séfense dans des
cas pratiques donc c'est effectivement
tout comme le CRAV Maga il y a il y a
des il y a de l'application concrète
immédiate c'est on on vous attrape c'est
du dégagement c'est on veut vous mettre
un coup c'est comment réagir c'est euh
c'est une réaction sur un coup de PO un
coup de tête ou même un coup de couteau
c'est une gestion de l'attitude aussi
c'est c'est tous ces aspects-l y a une
forte demande justement pour tout ça
parce que en ce moment il y a beaucoup
de cours qui naissent autour donc du
CRAV magaga vous l'avez mentionné
Anthony mais bon voà avec le oshinsou là
présent bien dit he vous avez vu ououi
bravo bravo il y a une forte demande oui
on ça fait plusieurs années que sur le
forum des associations on a des des gens
qui nous demandent alors donc les gens
ont peur alors alors les gens ont peur
je sais pas si c'est les gens ont peur
mais en tout cas ils ont peut-être
besoin juste d'être un peu
et et de savoir comment réagir on on on
donne ce type de d'enseignement aussi
sur nos cours au quotidien mais c'est
vrai que on voit que peut-être 5 ou 10 %
du programme sur un enseignement loisir
sur lequel on doit aussi enseigner le
reste de l'UR martial alors que là c'est
vraiment une section qui sera dédiée à
ça donc il aura rien de Martial il y
aura pas la tenue obligatoire c'est
vraiment un survette un t-shirt et puis
vas-y on y va voilà le le prof qui va
être devant vous qui va vous expliquer
donc comment ment réagir dans dans 10 et
les inscriptions dès à présent les
inscriptions dès à présent cours 15
novembre 15 novembre voilà sur cette
nouvelle se tous les jeudis soirs merci
beaucoup à vous deux d'être d'être venu
après ces ces beaux résultats et puis
nous suivrons l'ouverture de cette
section au shinsou le mi novembre merci
beaucoup on continue avec à présent du
tennis oui sans transition le le club le
Tennis Club de de Chevreuse affiche
clairement c'est ces ambitions au niveau
compétition pour cette nouvelle saison
être à la pointe tout simplement pour la
première fois de son histoire le TC
Chevreuse ouvre un pôle compétition ou
un centre d'entraînement peut-on dire
pour les jeunes âgés de 10 à 12 ans imag
d'élo di moine et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud les jeunes joueurs chevvretin
découvrent les souffrances de
l'entraînement physique depuis quelques
semaines 18 enfants âgés de 10 à 12 ans
ont intégré le premier pôle compétition
du Tennis Club de Chevreuse une
structure habituellement réservée au
club importants compétiteur dans l'âme
ces jeunes veulent continuer de se faire
plaisir pour le physique parce que
normalement je faisais que de 2 heur en
jouant au tennis et le physique je pense
que ça va m'aider à progresser au tennis
je souhaite surtout savoir bah bien
jouer au tennis et me faire plaisir qui
dit centre d'entraînement dit nouveau
régime tennis à raison de trois
entraînements par semaine dont 2 heures
consacrées à la condition physique tout
cela sous la halette de Patrick Charton
ancien coach de joueurs professionnel et
le parrainage un peu exceptionnel de
théophil Lantier et Axel Lony
participant au championnat de France des
15 16 ans ça me fait progresser parce
que
c'est Patrick qui me donne les conseils
et que je leur fait transmettre donc ça
me ça m'aide pour moi aussi
et donc aussi de l'expérience pour moi
ils sont bons et et ils jouent bien pour
moi c'est comme un exemple ouai avec
cette école de compétition l'objectif
est clair tutoyer à nouveau le haut
niveau le plus vite possible on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait une structure de 11
12 ans qui était plutôt qualitative et
quantitative donc on s'est dit c'était
quand même une belle une belle
expérience et on s'est dit bah ce serait
sympa de d'amener le plus de jeunes dans
ces catégories là de 11 12 ans en
seconde série pour pouvoir renouveler la
participation à ce championnat France
les compétiteurs devront faire 5
tournois dans l'année sur ce point le
match est déjà
gagné